Ngày Mui Sau thằng sau, công an thình phố Hà Nội đã tiên hành bắt sử phạm định tốn,
phó chủ tịch y bán nhân dân thiết chân chút sôn, hình chương miếp,
đề điều tra về hình vi sản xuất hàng giả là của Ní Tế.
Theo điều tra, tốn và em tra đã cùng nhau thành lập công viên hà để sản xuất của Ní Tế bệm mi đổ.
Tên nhân vi lợi nợ tốn đã chỉ đạo Ninh viên sản xuất của Nban Mê Tha Nòn chứ không phải bằng Eternon,
theo tỷ lệ bà mê phần chăm nước bệm mê phần chăm con,
với nghiệm viên trọng để xức khỏe cộng đồng.
Mình viện bệm mai mới đây tiếp nhận mạnh nhân năm 2019,
biểu đột mê Tha Nòn nặng xó khi sự dụ quân bệm mi đổ mô tại hiểu thuốc để xúc miệm chữa đau dàng.
Mạnh nhân viện trong tình trọng, ông Mê, xí hô hấp,
nhiễm tăng truyền hóa nặng, tổn thương náo, phải lập mẫu có cựu.
Sẽ nghiệm cho thấy lại của mạnh nhân dụng chứ tới bệm bệm bệm phẩy năm 2019,
cho nó lại khuôn công nghiệm không được phép dùng sát chung,
với đập với tình kinh và thị giá.
Theo chúng tâm trong độc, mấy việc bệm mai,
việc sự dụ quân giả đã gây nhiều càng hộ đột nghiêm trọng,
thậm chí từ vong trong những năm qua.
Cơ quan chức năng cần sết chặt quả lý,
kìm sốt hoa chất, đồng thời người dân chỉ nên mô con tại cơ sở y tính,
đọc ký thành phần, chẳng dùng khi nghiệm sần phẩm không só hồn gốc.